we have a voicemail number that you can call
anytime of day.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a really good practical question about getting
engaged in politics.
Take a listen to this.
Hi David.
My name is Carlos.
I've been trying to call it on the show for
awhile and haven't been successful.
So I thought I'd maybe a message.
And here's the question.
I know the big topic right now is impeachment,
some pressing issues, but one of the things
that I wanted to see you cover, I wanted to
hear your opinion on is how you think that,
um, the people who are somewhat less than
wealthy can enter politics successfully.
I've been interested in politics for many
years and I'm getting to a point in my career,
I'm kind of considering retiring and going
into politics, but yeah, not exactly Andrew
Yang or Tom [inaudible] or somebody else who
already has a whole bunch of them.
Right?
Oh, okay.
Somehow they got cut off.
I guess he was going to say a whole bunch
of money.
So here's the thing, this is a great question
to be asking.
Uh, what w we actually, we need more people
that don't come from the same three or four
industries in politics.
But you're right, if you are not in a financial
position that is a particularly strong, it's
going to be very difficult to become, for
example, a Senator.
Uh, it potentially, there are places as we
know, people like AOC who without a lot of
money have become, uh, elected members of
the house of representatives.
But that is also difficult.
The best thing to do is to get involved at
the local level.
And this accomplishes a lot of things.
Number one, to get on school boards, even
sometimes to run for city council.
I've seen people with no money get on city
councils in different places.
It doesn't take a lot of money to do it and
it's a great place to start, but it also does
something else that the left has been failing
out.
I've been talking for years to anyone who
will listen about how the left has been failing
at getting the bullpen built up, getting the
farm league built up.
Uh, and one of the best ways to do that is
by starting to get into the city councils
and the school boards and all of the other
things you can influence policy.
Yes, on a local level, but in ways that do
matter to the people in that community doesn't
require the out-sized resources that are often
required to run for higher office.
And it can be used if your aspiration is eventually
higher office.
It can be used as a precursor to start building
a following, building a coalition.
So that's what I would encourage you to do.
I have no idea where you live and what's available
in terms of government, but there are lots
of options you can get on the board of local,
non-commercial radio or television stations.
That's something I did back in North Hampton,
Massachusetts.
I wasn't on the board of NCTV North Hampton
community television now, uh, relaunched as
North Hampton, open media.
Uh, there are limitless options that require
very little money.
Some require no money whatsoever because these
positions are just open sometimes and you
can use them to get to other positions if
that's what you want.
So that would be my advice.
We will talk on the bonus show today about
stormy Daniels settlement over the disastrous
arrest at that Ohio strip club.
This is an old story that we're following
up on.
We will talk about cancer cases connected
to tap water contaminants, and we will talk
about a town in Ohio that has made election
day a paid holiday
by swapping it for Columbus day, which is
of course upcoming.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].